So, okay so let's, let's actually do some inferencing just to, to
kind of get a feel for it. For certain kinds of networks we
can do things exactly. And we're going to look at one of
those examples in just a moment. But, it turns out, helpful to
remind ourselves of some rules of probability in inference that will help
us do that. So, here's just kind of a little cheat sheet.
For you, so, marginalization is this idea that we can represent the
probability of, of a value, at, by summing over some other variable and
looking at the joint probabilities of those. And if, if
you've trouble remembering this one, this, this's how I like to
think about it, if we're trying to figure out the probablitiy
of x, then one way, one thing we can do is
break it up in. Break the world up into, well
the cases where x and, not y. Plus, places where x
and y. So, the probability of x is it can be
broken down into the probability of x when y is false
plus the probability of x when y is true. So
it's really simple in that sense, but it actually turns out
to be a useful thing to be able to do.
To marginalize out. The chain rule, we've used this a bunch
of times. The probability of x and y can be
written as the probability of x times the probability of y
given x. And that's important that we've the given X. If
we drop that then what is that implying? Just go ahead.
>> Well, if you drop that then it
implies that they are completly independent of one another.
>> Right, in the case where the variables
are independent, you can just look at their product.
In the general case you actually have to
look at the second one given the first one.
>> And as I recall, the order on the
left doesn't matter, so, you have the probability of X times
the probability of Y give X, but you could have written the
probability of Y times the probability of, X given Y.
>> Yes. And, actually, let's do a quick quiz.
>> Okay.